Hello Freak pitches.
Well,
and that's something that I think that we've historically had this really weird
approach to medicine,
which I think is kind of a secondary effect of thinking scientifically.
And,
um,
obviously I,
my background is in neuroscience.
I worked as a scientist for many years and I am very much a scientific thinker
and I'm all about the scientific method.
But I think that we sometimes are at fault when we're a little bit too
reductionistic and our views.
And so if you look at the history of modern medicine,
of signing a evidence based medicine,
what ends up happening is that we look at a problem and we try to fix the
problem and we look at it as if you can somehow cut that piece of the person's
physiology completely out of them,
solve it,
and then put it right back in.
And it doesn't have any effect on anything else in their bodies.
I mean,
you look at medication,
right?
Um,
any,
any form of pharmaceutical,
they all have side effects.
If you think about what a side effect is,
it,
it comes down to how medication works.
Medicine is a molecule.
It's some sort of molecule that fits in a receptors somewhere in your body.
And the idea is that you want it to have really high efficacy.
So let's say that I'm somebody who has a problem with um,
blood pressure for example,
or actually let's just jump into depression because I've been talking about this
a lot lately around um,
Robin Williams.
I had Paul Gil Martin on my podcast just last week to talk about that.
He hosts the mental illness happy hour podcast and has really great insights
into,
um,
mental illness.
And I of course publicly have dealt with depression most of my life.
I take medication every day.
I go to therapy every week.
I'm very open about it.
For a lot of people,
they would look at you,
especially people that don't have any issues with depression,
obviously very intelligent,
beautiful young.
Why would you be depressed,
tripping over themselves,
trying to date you,
you,
you're obviously very successful in pursuing intellectual pursuits.
Why would you be depressed?
Exactly.
Why we're getting,
a lot of people don't understand the differences between depression and sadness
and they don't understand that depression is a biological illness.
They don't think of it and they also don't think of it in terms of like people
look at it in terms of like,
well,
you've got all these sums,
these numbers.
Look,
there's all stack on that.
Almost Ken can make it worse for certain people.
I mean,
you look at somebody like Robin Williams,
he had so much going for him,
right?
He was famous,
he was loved.
He had all this money.
How could he be depressed?
He didn't have the problems that you are.
I have and you know what?
Then you have this extra layer of guilt.
You have this extra layer of shame,
this extra layer of why the fuck am I still depressed?
No matter how much success I get,
no matter how much money I make,
no matter how much people write me letters and say that they love me and
whatever,
I can't seem to to beat this feeling inside of me,
this constellation of symptoms because it's not coming from that.
It's coming from your brain and is it,
I mean,
I don't suffer from depression,
but I have had many friends who do and um,
I have always wondered what it's because it seems to be that when you go to a
doctor and they start treating it,
whether they treat it with medication or they try to adjust your diet and in
prescribed exercise first,
that there's no like one simple fix and everybody's completely different and
people get,
people get upset about that because I think it goes back to to kind of what I
was talking about before,
which is a meandering way to,
okay,
so again,
to go back to this idea of a drug,
you take a drug,
let's say I take an antidepressant.
My antidepressant specifically is a selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor,
an Ssri that's called [inaudible].
That's the off brand.
I think it's Alexa,
um,
is the brand name.
I take that it binds to my serotonin receptors in my brain and it allows me to
dump more serotonin into the synapse that the gap between two brain cells so
that I always have more available.
It basically tells my brain that I need more serotonin.
So I make more serotonin available to myself.
It's a,
it's a re uptake inhibitor.
And so,
um,
or sorry,
it keeps more serotonin in,
in the gap instead of sucking it back into the cell.
So I always have more available to me now it's a molecule,
it's got a shape just like anything out there.
It has geometry,
so it binds to this specific receptor in the brain because it got a similar
shape to that.
There are other things in your body that are similarly shaped.
And so what ends up happening is when you take a drug,
the specificity of the drug is only based on whether or not the key fits in a
locked somewhere in your body.
But let's say that you had hundreds of thousands,
millions of locks available to you and one key and you started going through,
you'd be able to stick that in a bunch of locks.
Some of them,
it might even turn,
but it would,
it would fit in the lock of multiple locks hanging on that wall.
So what ends up happening is I take this drug,
it binds in my brain.
It does what it's supposed to do in my brain,
but it also may be does other shit like makes me really fucking tired or it
makes it so I don't want to have sex as often.
It's a side effect.
And the reason that you have a side effect is because there's other parts of
your body that the drug binds to.
It's the same thing with medicine.
Like you were saying,
you operate on somebody whose heart,
the heart is connected to other things.
It's it,
it's the source of blood flow throughout your body.
It is connected to hormone levels.
There's all sorts of things that can happen when you put somebody on her under
anesthesia,
when you cut them open,
when you uh,
you know,
you,
you cause an immune response and inflammatory response there,
your body is a holistic thing.
And so when you start jacking with certain things,
other things are going to happen.
That doesn't mean you should throw the baby out with the bath water.
But medicine is a risk benefit analysis always.
How do they find the,
it seems to me that they find the right medication by experimentation that they
try it.
And is that just because it's,
cause we don't have any tests.
I can't,
you can't go up as a doctor.
You can't come to me,
stick a needle in my spinal cord,
take out my cerebral spinal fluid and measure how much their tone in I have in
it.
I wish you could.
I wish I could take some sort of a blood test or I could,
you know,
p and a cop and then you could analyze that p and say you're low on Saratonin.
You need an Ssri.
That would be what works for you.
Because other people's depression comes from problems with dopamine,
comes from problems with norepinephrine or some combination thereof.
But there's no test for it.
It fucking sucks.
There's no test for it.
And so what ends up happening is you have to play a musical chairs.
You try a drug,
maybe it does.
The first drug I tried for aunt,
uh,
when I decided to finally go on antidepressants,
fucked me up so bad.
I took an s,
n,
d r I,
a selective serotonin norepinephrine,
dopamine reuptake inhibitor.
I was so fucking depressed,
I couldn't function and we decided let's throw the book at it.
Let's take the drug of all drugs,
the monster drug that does everything and I couldn't sleep for a week.
I felt like I was on straight up crank,
like on crystal lot done.
I quit smoking.
No,
seriously,
I quit smoking.
It was awesome.
That's when I quit smoking.
That's an important point.
Terrible for your body.
Horrible.
Did you do anything to try to naturally stimulate your body to produce more
serotonin?
Did you try a lot of exercise?
Did you adjust your diet but you didn't quit smoking?
I did.
I mean ultimately got on the drugs only on the drug for a week.
So as soon as I got off the drug again,
I immediately wanted to smoke again.
But at that point I'd pushed through it and I said,
you know,
I'm,
I'm at my lowest.
I was at my lowest point I've ever been at.
So I was like,
fuck it can't get any worse.
And I did.
I quit smoking.
The thing about depression that is fascinating to me is that there are some
correlations between how do are you happy with what you choose to do with your
day.
I had a friend who was,
he was on like some serious
and they changed his life.
They got him,
he,
he quit his business,
he quit his job,
brother started his own business,
got involved in relationship,
and then once he got to a really good place,
he slowly weaned himself off the antidepressants and now he's great.
Yeah,
and that happens to a lot of people and so I think that there's different,
what we have to understand too is of course all psychiatric disorders or
spectrum disorders,
right?
There's really extreme examples and there's barely any examples.
And if anybody who's ever taken a psych course or who studied,
you know,
if you were a psych major in college,
you know that as you've studied the DSM four,
which is like,
it's called the diagnostic and statistical manual that they use in psychiatry
and psychology.
It's basically the big Bible of all the things you can be diagnosed with.
The more you study it,
the more you're like,
I have that.
Oh,
I totally fucking have that.
And you realize everybody has,
everybody can convince themselves that they have these,
it's like web MD,
you know what I mean?
So it's only once it is sufficient,
Lee,
detrimental to your life that it affects your relationships,
it affects your ability to work,
it affects your health,
whatever the case may be.
And usually within the DSM,
there maybe like eight things and it's like you have to have five out of these
eight things.
And so anybody can read it and go,
Oh,
I felt depression before.
But what they don't realize is there is a difference between depression and
sadness.
There's also a difference between parody depression.
So depression that lasts years,
decades,
and the type of depression that people get that's directly linked to life
events.
And that's your dog dies,
you look well,
a big one,
you lose your freaking job.
Like we've seen so many documentaries lately about this.
As the economy took a downturn,
people lose their job and then they end up committing suicide because they
can't.
It's like this cascade of awfulness.
That's a really common one.
Um,
you know,
family member dies,
you have a stillborn or you have an abortion or you how you have a baby,
a healthy baby.
Postpartum depression is incredibly common and in that case that's much more
common that people can take meds,
they can do all these things and once they get back to where they were before
that horrible life event,
they're okay to get off off the meds.
Some people are able to get their depression managed without medication
perfectly well.
Some people aren't.
Is the different reactions of different people have two different medication?
Is it because their depression has a different source or is it just a
biodiversity?
I think it's more of a biodiversity thing than a source thing.
I mean as sources,
hard to say.
So depression is both when you think about it.
Well,
brain and mind are the same thing.
Most modern neuroscientists say that brain and mind are two sides of the same
coin.
That mind is just an emergent property of brain.
Nobody's a dualist anymore.
They don't think that you can like heal the mind.
And it has no effect on the brain because it's the same fucking thing.
So there are,
you know,
some people's depression comes from the fact that their dopamine levels are,
are not healthy or they're norepinephrine levels are not healthy or whatever the
fuck.
But I think the common view of depression now is that there's some sort of
biological difference in your brain and oftentimes that's either caused or it
develops out of childhood or early life experiences where you know,
you have some sort of trauma or you have some sort of um,
development.
You have some sort of,
you know,
interaction with family,
whatever the case may be.
And it doesn't have to be,
you know,
you were molested as a child.
It can literally just be like you didn't feel,
um,
loved or whatever the case may be.
And you've got this brain difference combined with this emotional experience and
what ends up happening.
Because when you're very young,
you're brain is very plastic.
So when you're very young,
you're learning skills that are going to last you the rest of your life and
you're actually building your brain architecture,
certain neurons connecting and disconnecting and reconnecting and pruning out
the tree.
The beautiful tree that is all of the cells in your brain is getting pruned when
you're young and if you're depressed when you're young and you're experiencing
those kinds of things when you're young,
you're going to prune a tree that's prone to depression as you age because
you're going to keep reinforcing those neuronal connections.
That's why therapy is so important.
Meds in and of themselves are never going to get you in a place where your
depression has really well managed.
It's going to get you in a place where therapy is going to be working better for
you.
Meds are going to be an immediate and necessary interventional strategy so that
you're not crying or you're not trying to kill yourself or you're not.
Whatever your symptoms of so you can actually fucking get out of bed to work on
yourself.
That's what meds are there for me.
It.
Meds keep me from staying in bed all day.
That's a variable though.
Finding the right counselor has got to be incredibly difficult.
It's tough.
It's like I always liken it to the women who are listening to the podcast.
I liken it unto when you were first deciding to go on birth control,
a lot of women will go um,
to their gynecologist when they're 15,
16,
17 and say,
I want to go on birth control and they'll give them Ortho,
try cycling or whatever,
the pill,
the regular old pill,
and they'll be fine.
A lot of women will take the pill the first time and it'll make them really
sick.
Like every time they take the pill,
it makes them want to throw up or it gives them cramps or something's weird
about it.
It affects us and they go,
oh,
of this drug doesn't work for me and go,
Oh fuck,
okay,
let's try one with lower levels of estrogen or progesterone or let's try the
ring or the Depo Provera shot,
or maybe you need an Iud.
I was like that.
It took me multiple times to find the right drug.
And I think it's the same thing with therapy.
I think it's the same thing with psychiatric medicines.
It's not,
we're not monolithic,
so the same combination isn't gonna work for everybody.
And the truth is if that makes you afraid of modern medicine or if it makes you
think that psychiatry is Wu or something like that,
it's the same thing as cancer in many ways,
there's so many parallels.
Cancer's not one disease.
It's a spectrum of diseases.
If I got diagnosed with breast cancer and you got diagnosed with breast cancer
and we both went in with our diagnosis the same day,
our oncologist would give us different treatments because we would have
different genetic markers.
We would respond differently to different types of chemotherapy.
Chemotherapy,
it means chemical therapy.
It's a really big umbrella term for all the different kinds of cancer treatments
that are available.
Maybe you would get more radiation,
maybe I would need surgery,
but your metastasis would make it so that surgery wasn't a viable option.
It's,
it's a spectrum.
Disease and psychiatric illness or the same way.
The variable though of the counselor has to be kind of weird.
It is weird.
It's a weird find someone that you can confide in whole heartedly and it takes
time a really long time finding the correct sex.
Right.
Whether or not as some men do better with women counselors.
I have a male counselor,
um,
like I would never,
it's funny,
I have a male therapist but I have a female gynecologists like I would never in
a million let a dude like puts speculums and me and like dig around in my
cervix.
But I'm totally comfortable with a male therapist.
When did the depression started?
When I was child.
So you were dealing with it your whole life?
My whole life.
Oh completely.
Some of those years,
like when I was dating bill or when I would be moving,
those were some of the worst years because it was so stressful cause he didn't
have friends and because I was unmedical I was unmedicated then.
Yeah.
I didn't start taking medication until about three years ago.
Really got 27.
Did you try other methods you try?
I didn't try.
I tried some things and I,
I've been in therapy my whole life.
My parents first put me in therapy when they first started to decide that they
were thinking about getting a divorce and I was a young man.
I was maybe six or seven.
So from the time I remember,
I've understood the therapeutic process and they always really promoted that in
me.
So then even after the divorce and remarriage is and all of that,
I started doing the,
the therapy thing on my own.
Then when I went to college and I was very much on my own,
I went to college when I was 16 by the way,
and lived on my own at 60 I was fucking weird.
K Yeah,
so I was a little,
I'm an adult,
but I wasn't.
I did that.
I went to therapy.
I did all those things by myself,
but I always had this mental block.
I always had this like,
oh,
I don't need meds.
Meds means you're really crazy.
Meds means you really don't have control.
And not until I kind of hit a very bad rock bottom a few,
maybe three years ago did I finally say,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I've,
I think I actually have to do this.
I think it would be good for me.
And then it was the same experience that I've heard over and over and over from
people where finally they get on the meds that are right for them and they
calibrate to their dosage and maybe they've been on it for about two months and
they just have this epiphany of like,
why the fuck did I wait so long?
I could have felt like this my whole life.
What the fuck was I thinking?
Because you're so societaly.
We're so resistant to looking at mental illness the same way we look at physical
illness.
We're so,
it's so easy.
Paul Gil Martin just made this point when he was on my podcast last week.
If you went up to somebody with diabetes type one diabetes and you were like,
what the fuck dude?
Why don't you just think more positively so that your pancreas makes insulin?
Like what's wrong with you?
Why can't you just make more insulin?
It's like they'd be like,
what are you talking about?
It's the same thing with depression.
People put the onus on you.
Like they,
they look at it like it's a disease of will,
but it's not.
It's a,
it's a biological illness and that's just very hard for people to understand.
And so what you end up doing is carrying around a lot of guilt and shame and a
lot of feelings.
Like,
I'm not good enough.
I can't will myself out of this if I just think more positively.
It's not about that.
And I did that for years.
Years.
You just deal with it.
And I destroyed,
oh,
so many relationships.
I can only imagine.
I can only imagine being trapped in that scenario,
but I'm also very sensitive to the
variables that different people go through with their bodies.
I have hypothyroidism,
I have to take thyroid medication.
It runs in my family.
My mother has it grown.
Has it too.
Yeah.
And uh,
I,
I know I should get headaches,
these weird headaches at the end of the day where I was like,
ah,
so fuck.
Like I could fall asleep and it wasn't like,
it wasn't like I was like,
now I,
I get tired,
I go to sleep.
But it was like I could fall asleep just watching TV and be out for like eight
hours.
Like it didn't make any sense.
It was like a weird tired,
like I was in pain.
So,
uh,
and I get these weird headaches.
And then once I finally got on medication,
it was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
right.
You're like,
oh,
this is,
this is what other people feel like,
right?
Like I thought I was normal because that's another thing.
There's such a stigma in this country,
not just about mental illness,
but about any sort of illness where people can't openly freely talk about it.
So you end up living in this weird bubble where you don't really,
like,
I know people that have mental illness that didn't even realize they had mental
illness until they finally had a conversation with a doctor about it and they
were like,
oh,
this isn't normal.
Like not everybody doesn't hear voices or everybody does it.
It's like,
yeah,
because you're so afraid to talk to somebody about it.
So that's,
I mean that's a really important part of this.
I think it's just getting past the stigma.
That's why when something like this with Robin Williams,
which is so fucking depressing happens,
a lot of people rally around it and they say,
hey,
maybe we can use this as a teaching moment because this guy,
no matter how good his life was,
he had this thing that he ultimately couldn't kick and it wasn't his fault.
It just is that way sometimes and hey,
maybe you have it too.
I think in some ways it's good when high functioning people come out and talk
about their illnesses because then people who are actually experiencing things
like loss of employment,
loss of a loved one,
whatever,
or who have had a bad go of it for other reasons or like even you,
like you had said before,
like even you,
but you're pretty or,
but you're successful and you're whatever.
Well,
if you could have that,
then of course,
it's not weird that I have,
you know,
it's like it's a good thing for people to be able to see that they're not alone
like that.
Yeah.